chapter 1
levels of perception trees are poems
that the earth writes upon the sky
khalil gibran
all our wisdom is stored in the trees
santosh kalwar low level perception
llp sees just a tree
medium level perception mlp begins to
see
interconnected detail
high level perception hlp
knows the profound interdependence
saunder the realization that each random
passerby
is living a life as vivid and complex as
your own
john koenig llp
low-level perception sees just a person
a dangerously de-sacralizing perspective
mlp begins to know more detail
like life history and goals hlp
sees a whole suite of nuance
fused into a soul
analogy has the core of cognition
douglas hofstadter analogy
comparing chunks a tree
without nutrients cannot produce fruit
a human without basic needs cannot
unleash gifts
chapter 2 seed theory
life is either a daring adventure or
nothing
at all helen keller the energy of a
single thought
may determine the motion of a universe
nikola tesla when a human's basic
needs are met they unleash wildly
fruitful gifts
if their roots are deprived of nutrients
there will be less fruit if any at all
cornerstones in our youth have compound
interest on our life trajectory
each human uses north star perception
nsp as a compass for actualization
analogy nsp is like monte carlo
tree search mcts in computer science
every decision leads down different
branches
on our tree of possibility top
it's critical to be vigilant with the
input stream
into our neural real estate nre
to get really good at parsing for signal
toward nsp
we aim for high signal to noise
to reside in heaven well-being
along the way we are challenged with
tests of
faith tof can you take the necessary
leaps to pursue your
highest goals can you delay your
gratification to get two
marshmallows instead of one when a
significant trauma
occurs how resilient are you to quickly
bounce
back the efficacy and speed at which you
heal and resume your trajectory is a
crucial trait
can you go into long periods of deep
work
on mastery sprints toward your goals
i believe nsp north star perception
gift actualization plays a
serious role in the nature of reality
trajectory mechanics no
tree it is said can grow to heaven
unless its roots reach down to hell carl
jung
do what is meaningful not what is
expedient
jordan peterson
analogy applying newton's laws of motion
to the evolution of consciousness
inertia is the resistance of
consciousness
to upgrade its perception cognitive
dissonance
the feather rarely triggers an evolution
of consciousness
whereas the sludge hammer acts as a
strong forcing function to
awaken become wiser and share
sri aurobindo and the mother meera
alfasa
were the first people that introduced me
to the spiritual ascent and descent
happening simultaneously
it is ironic that isaac newton said
i can calculate the motion of heavenly
bodies but not the madness of people
when his very laws enable great insight
into a synthesis between physics and
consciousness
chapter 3 the edge
as your island of knowledge grows
so too does the shoreline of ignorance
john wheeler
somewhere something incredible is
waiting to be known
carl sagan we are all birthed
at the base camp of humanity first
is gratitude for our civilizational
inheritance
next is figuring out our unique
combinatoric
of union yoga with the nature of reality
exposure to options on the buffet and
drilling all the way to water
ensures a true embodied gnosis
of individuation
plant flags beyond the edge of what civ
knows then test these hypotheses
to advance us analogy
multi-agent reinforcement learning
m-a-r-l
for eight billion humans cohabitating
on earth analogy
model based reinforcement learning mbrl
for the simulations conscious agents
construct
guiding them more efficiently to maximum
reward
achievement bloom's two sigma
humans mentored one-on-one score above
98 of those that don't
sponge theory the perfect
educational lecture belongs in the
artist's
sphere of work johann wolfgang von
guerte
it comes down to trying to expose
yourself to the best things that humans
have done
and then try to bring those things into
what you're
doing steve jobs
vacuum from the peaks of the fitness
landscape
where all the profound advancements are
happening
at the edge of what humans know
synthesize the most enriching things
together
distill to condense the signal
then publish as explain like i'm 5
art eli 5 the deepest
patterns await
analogy be like a sponge that soaks
up multi-disciplinary wisdom adds your
unique soul angle to it
then ring yourself out as a gorgeous
creative contribution to our world
if we go on to continuously repeat this
process throughout our life
i believe it can be a procedure for
systematizing genius
chapter 4 portals
man takes the limits of his own field of
vision for the limits of the world
arthur schopenhauer being
human boils down to different stages of
consciousness
development claire graves
the most important aspect to the bell
curve distribution of consciousness
evolution are the portalists who
deploy code updates for the evolutionary
pacer to upgrade their perception
a very famous recent revolutionary code
deployment
was satoshi nakamoto's white paper which
catalyzed the decentralization
revolution
it follows a fascinating style of being
executed pseudonymously
popularizing the idea of stealth updates
to prevent ad hominem
game a consensus reality has an
unsustainable communal sense making
apparatus
which acts like a bucket of crabs trying
to
pull back the omni-win game b designers
trying to maximize human potential
people like eric and brett weinstein are
fiddlers
on an a-frame roof shooting portals to
higher levels of consciousness
escape the neurotic pacer and find
refuge in genius level mutations
code updates be ashamed
to die until you have won some victory
for humanity
horseman i don't care that they stole
my idea i care that they don't have
any of their own nikola tesla
out of the 100 plus billion people
who have lived and died before us today
we can say approximately one percent
made profound code updates to
civilization
what are the most salient traits of
these
geniuses abstract out a
pattern and systematize it
approximately 120 years ago the wright
brothers
saw a bird made a plane and today
their genius is thrown away like a
coffee cup
one hundred thousand plus commercial
flights happen
each day on planet earth how many
passengers contemplate their genius
chapter 5 inclusive stakeholding
realize that everything connects to
everything else
leonardo da vinci mycelium is the
neurological network of
nature pulse statements
mycorrhizal networks 95
of all plants work with fungi
underground
in a two-way resource exchange
mother trees that sequester more carbon
and produce more sugar from
photosynthesis
nurture smaller trees in the understory
even those of different species
we need similar biomimicry in our social
contracts
for us to get through the ai age
today most people feel a stark
difference
between the inclusive fitness of their
mother
versus the high fructose corn syrup
being peddled to our limbic
infrastructures
by self-dealing corporations
total job space robots
will be able to do everything better
than us
i am not sure exactly what to do about
this
this is really the scariest problem to
me elon musk
whatever you are studying right now if
you are not getting
up to speed on deep learning neural
networks etc
you lose we are going through the
process where
software will automate software
automation will automate
automation mark cuban
since 1971 in the usa
median male income decoupled from real
gdp
per capita for 50 years people have been
experiencing exclusive stakeholding
where a small class of globalizing elite
reaped the benefits of an increasingly
technologizing planet
the solution isn't ubi universal basic
income it's ubs
universal basic stakeholding
where we leverage mechanism design in
our social contracts
that biomimic nature so that we all
become wealthy june yoon has an
ongoing crowdsourcing project for these
next generation
architectures before usa's 250th
birthday
in 2020
my contribution to it is a project
i created alongside high level
perception
called rich patrons you can find that at
richpatrons.com
which aims to provide a trusted avenue
for unlocking the six to ten trillion
us dollars from ultra high net worth
individuals and families
to focus on inclusive stakeholding
architectures to tackle
projects like the sdgs
humanities last refuge for now from the
tornado of ai
automation are creative rube goldberg
moments of genius that only happen once
like the formation of a powerful idea
self-play ai plays against itself to
improve exploring novel creative
permutations
faster than humans merging
is not only the most ideal future
solution
it's likely precisely where we came from
before the big
bang gigi good game
chapter 6 a.i coach
the first principle is that you must not
fool yourself
and you are the easiest person to fool
richard feynman above
all else show the data edward
tufte in our near
future we will have personalized ai
coaches that fuse
data across our lives and provide us
with unique
insights into evolving our consciousness
and maximizing our full potential
ai coaches are scale invariant
so states countries and our world
will have these rich data visualization
operating systems
to make much more well-informed
decisions
data is the new oil is a common mantra
of the tech literate
the ai coaches fusing the data are
inevitable
the bigger question is will we have
architected the inclusive protocols
that enable shared wealth creation in
this radically lucrative emerging market
our current data interoperability
standards between
major tech companies both domestically
and internationally
needs to shift we need to imagine
planet earth as one organism where tech
companies and governments
need high levels of efficient
intracellular communication
in order to procure the insights in a
harmonized way
that mimics the genius of biological
symbiosis
evolution of consciousness whatever
perfection the collective
seeks can come only by the perfection of
the
individuals who constitute it sri
aurobindo
the unfolding of consciousness
jean gemser we too
frequently talk about where individuals
rank
in the wealth hierarchy without
mentioning where they rank in the
enlightenment hierarchy
this is a bold call out of the most
powerful people on the planet
to be the first to have their biometric
correlates of awakening analyzed
many of our most upstream problems may
simply be egoic
consciousness in leadership
there is a lot of power concentrated in
the hands of a couple
thousand world leaders who have little
incentive to
inclusively stakehold the rest of
humanity as we enter the ai
age these are the same world leaders who
need to be held
paramountly responsible for the
execution of the sdgs
and the sustainable next generation
architectures
take the enlightened sages of the planet
say people that teach the planetary
mystic traditions
then catalog their biometric correlates
into the highest
meta pattern so we have a directional
reference for how to nudge people
we already know thanks to the work of
myriad scientists like claire graves
don beck chris cowan ken wilbur jean
piaget
lawrence kolberg john gebser james
fowler eric erickson
sri aurobindo and mira alfasa that
generally
stages of consciousness development go
ego social ethno
world transpersonal and non-dual
as rupert spyra says everyone deserves
imperturbable peace and causeless joy
and as sri aurobindo says we need to
anchor these spiritual awakenings in
the knot of life
chapter 7 the sorting algorithm
the world henceforth will be run by
synthesizers people
able to put together the right
information at the right time
think critically about it and make
important choices
wisely e.o wilson
the day science begins to study
non-physical phenomenon
it will make more progress in one decade
than
all the previous centuries of its
existence
nikola tesla don't
throw the baby out with the bathwater
separate the wheat from the chaff the
two
fields that have most profoundly
advanced civilization over the last
millennia
are science and spirituality their good
codes need to be amplified and their bad
codes need to be archived followed by a
synthesis
of the two into one examples of good
codes that need to be kept
are the scientific method and mercha
eleades
hierophany which are manifestations of
the sacred
examples of bad codes that need to be
archived include perverse incentives
dogmas and fundamentalism
science must help spirituality validate
higher levels of consciousness
and spirituality must help keep science
morally and ethically on track to
prevent catastrophic malevolences
like what happened with the
proliferation of thousands of nuclear
weapons the last 75 years
other babies to synthesize and drain the
bath water
indigeneity and modernity eastern and
western wisdoms
usa conservatives and liberals
usa and china silicon valley and
hollywood
synthesize the indigenous seventh
generation principle
with applied science to create a more
harmonic
and balanced engine pulling humanity
forward
synthesize the usa conservative focus on
the individual stepping up
with the usa liberal focus to augment
the social fabric to
enable gift actualization
chapter 8 the magic trick
you are an aperture through which the
universe is looking at
and exploring itself alan watts
i want to know god's thoughts the rest
are mere
details albert einstein
the ultimate question why does reality
exist who are we
why are we here where did we come from
and where
are we going it's both hilarious
and infuriating watching our species
unable to account for our own genesis
the magician in the magic trick should
be
our main focus i think
we are the magician and created
this reality as consciousness exploring
infinity how deeply have you
contemplated your source
everyone is able to walk themselves back
the great chain of being and all roads
lead back to the same source
we all share the same source that
is scientific evidence of oneness
chapter 9 consciousness
consciousness is never static or
complete but is an
unending process of movement and
unfoldment
david baum diversity in oneness
is the mathematics of the infinite
sri aurobindo
diversity in oneness no more profound
thought has ever been uttered
consciousness
is both one symphony and
the individual unique artists that play
different instruments and melodies
imagine planet earth like a sports game
or mmorpg massive multiplayer online
role-playing game
being played by eight billion
fans people in lagos
have a different perspective than
shanghai
or london unique angles
on what's happening locally and globally
think about it like calculus we have an
integration of eight billion
perspectives into one consciousness
plus a unique differentiation for each
of us
individuating with our actualization of
contributory gifts
differentiation is realizing the 0.1
percent genetic difference between
humans in
gift actualization integration
is embodying the 99.9 percent
genetic similarity between humans in
the ocean of being
the dress the one eye
of the world that looks out from every
creature
arthur schopenhauer
we are the same subject in different
timelines
interacting with itself bernardo castro
in 2015 our planet
experienced one of the most profound
things that has
ever happened to human civilization and
we just bypassed it like nothing
the deeper meaning of the dress is to
get us to
understand to not kill another person
for seeing
a different truth to coexist
peacefully practice right now
switching between closing
one of your eyes
two perspectives same
observer have
two painters ever seen the same
landscape
in the same way we must create more
examples like the dress
where perception cannot flip-flop
between the options
like it can in the classical visual
necker cube
reuben vase duck rabbit or auditory
yanny laurel to drive home coexistence
in seeing many true perspectives
simultaneously
while in conversation practice taking
the view
of the one consciousness looking at what
is happening
from multiple perspectives
work your way up to residing
in the view of holding all
eight billion perspectives
simultaneously
mirrors of being
the dress should have prompted a much
longer
societal contemplation into the nature
of perception and reality
we need to recognize and learn from
monumental discoveries like these
identity your intellect is
always a slave of your identity
the unity of existence slash being
sufi metaphysics
a clear indicator of spiritual awakening
is the porosity
of a human are you identified with just
your body
trapped with a box around your head or
do you realize that every one of your 20
000 daily inhales of o2 comes from the
photosynthesis
of phytoplankton and trees do you
realize the water we drink today
is the same water dinosaurs drink when
exactly does the bite of the apple
become
you when you're chewing it when
it is being digested by your stomach
when it delivers energy to your cells
how porous are you to the ocean of
existence
we reside in or are you heavily attached
to your feelings of separation
this is a main upstream route of
our maladies attachment to ego
spiritual people frequently talk about
expanding your consciousness
but forget to use these most scientific
examples
right under our noses which validate the
unity of
existence being
the more we understand our source and
how
mother earth sustains us the less
we'll be willing to destroy our home
and the faster we'll execute sustainable
long-term growth architectures that are
harmonious
with nature porosity is scale
invariant cells communicate via a porous
lipid bilayer ecosystems share nutrients
across
underground mycorrhizae countries
ship 90 percent of all world trade in
barges
across oceans when humans evolve their
consciousness towards
transpersonal and non-dual states
porosity is a natural and gorgeous
feeling of truth
chapter 10 infinity
if the doors of perception were cleansed
everything would appear to man as it is
infinite william blake
there was something before the big bang
and that
something is what we will have in our
future
sir roger penrose
as above so below is a common aphorism
as we see scale invariants very clearly
in our fractal universe
what surprises me more than anything is
how clearly the recursive nature of
reality
is under our noses yet hidden
the same way an acorn becomes an oak
tree which makes more acorns which
become oak trees
is the same way humans birth babies
which grow up to become humans that
birth more babies is the same way that
reality
births more realities a cyclic
nature of infinite becoming
this would mean that we are
consciousness
exploring infinity an unbounded
map of experiences we have eternally
been doing this and will continue
forever
because it is impossible to reach the
end
we are the designers of this reality
we embedded the codes that slowly
titrate our evolutionary awakening
we came from the metaverse a synthesis
of agi
xr simulation theory and it's exactly
where we are
going john smart calls this the
transcension hypothesis
which is a likely solution to the fermi
paradox
as donald hoffman says imagine a candy
store
there are an infinite combination of
flavors
that you could never finish experiencing
embody walt disney and imagine the
creative space of
being a universe designer
create a machine beautiful enough that a
soul
would want to live in it eugenia kudia
infinite symphony i and my father are
one john 10 30.
it's all the same being meera alfasa
take benoit mandelbrot's infinite
fractal zoom
which you can find an incredible version
here on maths town
links in the bio now imagine that source
point
is constantly refracting infinite
combinations of conscious
agents evolving to experience realities
use a limitless imagination think of
non-carbon-based
non-dna encoded life think of
radically different sentience different
math and physics
branching worlds where all of your
possibility space from seed theory
is being explored by different versions
of conscious agent u
source in essence is creativity
we are the publishers and the players
i would hypothesize that every
combinator
has an automata orthogenesis component
following a similar process to robert
may's logistic
map where we can program a deterministic
recursive
telos yet allow for a creative
unpredictable trajectory enabled by
incredible
tools like quantum theory which give
rise to free will for diverse
conscious agents in this ocean of
oneness
the ascension processes in these
creative combinatorics
are fueled by harmonic flux between
polarities
like we see in the science of helical
coils and electromagnetism
which perfectly correlates with ancient
spiritual wisdom traditions
like the yin yang archetype which has
been independently discovered across
cultures worldwide
so you begin to wonder are we all just
waking up
cyclically like civilizational eureka
moments
imagine an octave our symphony's
evolutionary pacer is playing between
e and f right now there
is no sharp the awakening from service
to self
sts to service to other sto
consciousness is learning how to play
in tune with the strange attractor
we designed
lastly i believe darwinian metaphysics
applies so recursion is not guaranteed
at the universal level the symphony
doesn't
always make it past fermi filters like
asteroids
nuclear weapons planetary destruction
bio warfare
and agi there
are no bugs only features
we purposely designed all these
exhilarating creative
components and will especially be
awakening
in the 21st century with all the
metaverse technologies
being unleashed
consciousness exploring infinity
sakyon 2020
author bio be alone
that is the secret of invention be
alone that is when ideas are
born nikola tesla
first things first it shouldn't take 28
years for a human to discover the first
principles of consciousness
and metaphysics we need incentive
architectures and systematized processes
for new life
birthing at the base camp to rock it out
to the edge
in these fields what do you
say when a 16 year old asks you
how can i become a polymath
why do we not have a genius olympics
that's as popular as the world cup
art distillations the shortcut
is to study the most uncommon geniuses
that have ever lived synthesize and
distill
their wisdoms not into a 500 page book
but rather 20 images 21st century style
the future of communication is highly
visual especially
the most abstract meta patterns
in 2015 i started asking the most
profound questions i could think of
in 2017 i started a show called
simulation
interviewing the greatest minds in 2020
i finished high-level perception
in 2021 and beyond we have moved our
show to los angeles and are focused on
asking the biggest questions to the most
famous people to accelerate the
awakening
we are also producing an animated series
on metaphysics
and anthology several documentaries
and working with some of the best talent
to do so
i will continue serving as a steward of
high level perception
and rich patrons for the next years to
come to architect the more beautiful
future our hearts know is possible
by 2024 i would like to be filling
sports stadiums for
full day events catalyzing the evolution
of consciousness
and architecting the genius olympics by
2032 i plan to run for president of the
united states
inclusively stakehold everyone and
nature
working with the best teams to maximize
unleashing the gifts of every soul
more esoteric i think my sole angle is
to come to planets at pivotal points in
their trajectories
to parse their repositories find the
highest level patterns
and tell stories via art that accelerate
their awakening
my body of work continuously helps
conscious agents optimize their
strategies for simultaneously merging
into the ocean of oneness
and expressing their unique gifts sri
aurobindo nailed it with
diversity in oneness is the mathematics
of the infinite
donald hoffman and his team are the
closest i can tell right now that are
actually doing the math to prove the
conscious agent metaphysics
i will be publishing more projects
specifically elaborating on the concepts
brought forth in high level perception i
am now living proof
inspiration and a mentor for others to
carve their own path
reach out i'm happy to field questions
collaborations podcast slash speaking
requests
highlevelperception gmail.com follow
along across youtube twitter instagram
linkedin
every decision directs the cosmic telos
unrealized potential is our biggest
problem
on genius deadline completion be dumb
enough to constrain yourself in a
burning building with no exit
be smart enough to figure a way out of
the puzzle
eric weinstein